[Music]
thank you
this is Sky News Tonight live in Kiev
for a special program on the Russian
invasion of Ukraine
the battle for Kiev buildings hit by
missile strikes as Russian forces
approach the capital
cues for weapons as residents take up
arms and the government tells them to
make fire bombs
and the desperate attempts to flee with
thousands of people heading for
Ukraine's Western borders
outside the capital Russia's Onslaught
continues with hundreds more attacks
right across the country
in Moscow Vladimir Putin claims he's
ready to negotiate but tells Ukraine's
military to seize power
and NATO bolsters its flank deploying
combat-ready troops to its eastern
borders and sending air defenses to
Ukraine
[Music]
good evening from Kiev where residents
have taken up arms with Russian forces
just a few miles outside the city center
the mayor of Kiev says the city has now
entered a defensive phase with civilians
being urged to make molotov cocktails
and take on invading troops across the
country there have been hundreds of
attacks today and thousands of people
have fled the violence Russian troops
made their way towards Kiev in a column
of military vehicles entering Ukraine
from Belarus
the Russian military then made their way
through past the former nuclear power
station at Chernobyl the shortest route
to the capital here
tanks were later spotted in Ukraine's
Capital with authorities telling
residents to stay off the streets due to
active hostilities our first report
tonight comes from Skies Chief
correspondent Stuart Ramsey
[Applause]
be under no doubt this European capital
is fast turning into a Battlefield
there are troops on street corners and
under bridges armored vehicles
constantly crisscross the city
bolstering positions waiting for the
enemy
the Ukrainian military are fighting but
they will struggle to hold on
tanks apcs and trucks maneuver beneath
the road arches
they're attempting to Shield themselves
from attack from the skies
holding on until the Russian infantry
and paratroopers attempt to get further
into Kiev by Road and on foot
well that's the expectation anyway
there's been a huge Exodus from the city
those Left Behind attempt to thumb lifts
heading west others stopped passing cars
and ask if they're heading their way
more often than not it's a fruitless
hope
the air raid sirens are irregular now
it's scary stuff
with their belongings they try to hurry
off the streets
most head for the Metro stations trying
to get Underground
[Music]
moms and dads and their little ones
trying to find safety if they can't find
a way out
[Music]
everyone feels exposed
everyone feels vulnerable
well it's a haunting sound as a of the
air raid sirens
is pushing people into taking cover
because heard a Crump of an explosion
it's like this all over the city now
foreign
exactly where and when the Russians May
attack a new Target remains unknown of
course so there's constant movement
much of the city is now deserted hardly
any people in the center of town just a
few cars driving between homes or
looking for a few shops that are still
open
and on the streets as well civilian
militia armed and ready to support the
army
foreign
explosions woke everyone in Kiev as the
Russian Mission continues
fiery debris falling onto residential
buildings below
this is life in Kiev now the country's
present making exactly that point
one bonds fall on Kiev it happens in
Europe not just in Ukraine when missiles
kill our people it is the death of
Europeans I demand greater security for
Europe greater protection for Ukraine as
part of a democratic world
foreign
many of the Ukrainian soldiers are very
young and inexperienced
21 year old Sergey petrochenko is the
only Soldier guarding a Footbridge he
has fired 16 rounds in his life
now he waits for the Russians his home
Village has already fallen
there are Russian bays in my Village
and from my Village they're gonna
uh go here on the queue
to capture it
yeah it's really scary and terrifying I
am called to my parents they really
scared there's Russians in our village
enemies
there's
tanks
heavy vehicle
I hope that they will be fine
foreign
[Applause]
s they descended onto the Central
Railway Station to try to get seats on
any trains West it was chaotic and
desperate
but that's what it's like here now
the fear of the unknown is what's so
difficult for everyone
Ukraine holds its breath while the world
watches on
Mr Ramsay Sky News Kiev
well of course it's not just here in
Kiev there's intense fighting all over
the country as Russian troops advance
from the north from the south and the
East and in the face of the threat from
their much better equipped neighbor
ukrainians have been using whatever
means they can to defend themselves
Sky's security and defense editor
Deborah Haynes reports now on the
military tactics being employed by both
sides
lives turned upside down
this was the door to a balcony that no
longer exists
Valentina was sleeping here when the
explosion happened
she and her teenage daughter are lucky
to be alive
[Music]
residents and pets in this neighborhood
in eastern Kiev left stunned as the
reality of Russia's Invasion hit home
they're unclear what caused the crater
with one man suggesting it happened
after Ukraine's air defenses intercepted
an incoming Russian airstrike
the worse the fighting gets the greater
the risk becomes for civilians of
getting caught in the middle residents
at this apartment block described how
they were woken up at between 4 4 30 in
the morning via a loud explosion they
said the night sky lit up like daylight
and when Dawn broke they found this
devastation
Russia's invading troops identifiable by
The Zed are attacking from the north
east and south
the plan seems to be to take control of
the Southern Coastline such as here in
Hassan and push into the east
[Music]
this Ukraine's Second City of khakive
under heavy bombardment terrifying for
residents and challenging for Ukraine's
military as other Russian forces close
in on the capital
a battle for this Airfield in the
northwest of Kiev finally won by Russian
troops after heavy fighting
sign of things to come perhaps Russia's
president called on Ukrainian forces
effectively to switch allegiances using
false smears about Ukraine's leaders
what's the apparent Russian military
vehicle crush a car in the north of the
capital the driver lucky to escape
yet Russia is suffering losses too
this aircraft was shot down over Kiev by
Ukrainian forces our assessment as of
this morning is that Russia has not
taken any of its major objectives in
fact it is behind its hoped for
timetable they've lost over 450
personnel and indeed as you've said on
your report one of the significant
airports they were trying to capture
with their Elite Spetsnaz has failed to
be taken and in fact the ukrainians have
taken it back
but this isn't just a conventional War
listen to the gunfight at this Security
office in the southern city of Malita
Paul as it's attacked by soldiers who
don't have obvious markings on their
uniform
Russian special forces are thought to be
on the ground conducting sabotage
missions the ultimate goal to topple the
president here on Friday rallying his
people
foreign
even civilians are being handed weapons
and urged to fight
a sign of desperation but also of the
prospect of a grinding Guerrilla war
that could in the end cost Russia daily
too the brain Sky News Kiev
meanwhile in the south of this country
Russian attacks have spread along
Ukraine's Coastline throughout the day
both Crimea and the donbass regions have
been entry points for Russian troops to
make their way into Ukraine the two
areas were already hosting large numbers
of troops before the full invasion it
appears Russia wants to close off
Ukraine's access to the Black Sea which
could have a severe impact on supply
routes Sky correspondent Alex Rossi
reports now from mariopol
it has been an horrific 24 hours
the hospital directors take me to see
soldiers injured on the Eastern fronts
Alex Rossi
staff Lieutenant Andre was lacerated
with shrapnel he's heavily medicated but
says as soon as he's recovered he wants
to fight again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
has just come out of surgery he's in
pain
Dr Alexi says he expects to see many
more blast injuries in the days to come
over
foreign no more which
is
but it's unlikely any help will arrive
Mario Paul like the rest of the country
is besieged and on its own
the people here are exhausted they stay
inside unless they need supplies but
after years of fighting they're inured
to the sound of War most don't even
Flinch when the shells start flying
we're on the outskirts of Mario Paul in
the eastern district the front lines are
over in that direction we've been
listening to the sound of a very heavy
artillery battle
it's hard to say exactly how far it is
away but it sounds as though Russian
forces are getting now much closer to
the city
and a sphere hovers over this place a
steady stream of evacuees are getting
out whilst they can
this man's putting his wife and daughter
on the train to safety before he goes
back in the army
foreign
many families will be separated in the
days to come and with the Russian
invasion battering every corner of this
country there's no doubt there will be
many more tears Alex Rossi Sky News
Mario Paul
right let's try to find out what is
happening right now our chief
correspondent Stuart Ramsey is live now
on the streets of Kiev this evening and
Stuart I'm sure you've been hearing what
we've been hearing which are a number of
explosions and repeated gunfire
yeah a lot of that and it's been going
on for the last few hours it's not quite
now I'm sure it's going to start again I
don't think either of us are going to
sleep very well uh tonight Mark
um are you right it's not just the
explosions I'm pretty certain I could
hear uh gunfire as well and we know from
earlier today we were up into the North
and we knew at one point as we were
coming back we were only about eight
kilometers away uh from where we're
staying now and you had that distinct
impression that the Russians were really
really near we saw the various defensive
positions of the Ukrainian military they
were moving their trucks around they
were taking cover as you saw in my
report underneath Motorway Bridges to
stop being attacked from the air
um and you definitely get that sense
don't you that we're really moving
towards the end game I know analysts on
Sky News have been saying Russia will
have this by the end of the night you
can never be that accurate but it
certainly has that feel now that they're
reading here and some of the explosions
have been very close to here us here and
also some of it has been outgoing from
artillery positions which are not far
away which a worry for everyone who
lives in this area because obviously
they will be targeted and attacked as
well and as we've seen in the reports
the concern is always about the civilian
population who is caught up in all of
this who are not taking up arms and who
are basically just hiding in basements
or areas that they've been told are say
for them basements in in all sorts of
different buildings
um it's a very tense evening it's been a
very very tense day actually a massive
change in 24 hours people are really
scared and of course we've seen as many
as possible
piling into cars driving themselves that
was particularly yesterday today trying
to get lifts and then obviously on the
train station which was fairly
horrendous with hundreds and hundreds
thousands of desperate people trying to
get out of Kiev with the Russians really
really close now
Stuart thank you very much let's go down
to uh Southeastern Ukraine now speak to
Alex Rossi who is in Mario poll Alex
what is happening where you are tonight
well it's been a very noisy day here to
Mark we have heard throughout the day
the thud the Crump of barrages of
artillery both incoming and also
outgoing we traveled to the outskirts of
the city the very furthest point in the
eastern district where the high-rise
blocks of flats give way to open grounds
and a very fierce battle going on again
very hard to say how close that fighting
is to the city but it it sounded much
closer than it was uh 24 hours ago now I
am actually inside the city not far away
from the coast we won't give away our
exact location we've been asked by the
people that we're staying with to move
away from the coastal front because of
our lights we don't want to draw
attention uh to where we are but in the
last hour we have heard some of the most
intense uh artillery that we've heard
since we have been here there are also
reports that there have been there has
been an amp amphibious assault somewhere
along the coastline here possibly
Russian Marines Landing we haven't been
able to verify that but this area would
be somewhere that you could expect that
kind of invasion force uh to land now
obviously for the people here the
civilians is well it's an extremely
nervous tense difficult time they're
waiting holding their breath really to
see what happens but the next 24 hours
will be crucial
yeah okay Alex thank you very much well
our correspondent John Sparks is into
nepro in eastern Ukraine and John the
last time we spoke I think was this
morning when you were in khakiv and
there was a lot of shell fire going on
yeah that's right uh mark it was uh it
was pretty frightening to to be honest
we spent much of the day in harkeefe
second largest city in uh Ukraine and I
can tell you at the moment they are
experiencing very very large very loud
blasts explosions on the outskirts of
the city and there's been a long day of
that and actually started just as I was
getting ready to to speak to you at
about 11 o'clock local time these loud
thuds these Echoes uh let these loud
thuds from echoing around uh the city
and we had to sort of keep the
conversation pretty short because it was
it felt like it was getting pretty
pretty close to us we were staying in a
city center hotel and we dashed it we
dashed inside but um
City officials said they found parts of
Russian smirch Rockets embedded in the
ground in front of several key buildings
and in actually in in the asphalt in the
road and this despite Russian officials
saying that they weren't going to Target
civilian areas at all we've been in
touch with residents through the day
they've been in and out of the shelters
in basements in in metro metro stations
and in designated Airaid shelters as
well although we were told that the air
raid sirens weren't actually working for
much of the day but they do have other
means to find out what's going on and we
just spoke to one contact a few minutes
ago she said at the moment they think
aircraft are actually bombing the city
as we speak now we took the road down to
denipro a lot of evidence of Ukrainian
Army the military both sides of the road
I don't think they're laying down there
are their arms I don't think they're
ready to give up
okay John thank you very much indeed and
that really gives you an idea of what's
Happening uh in three or four cities
different cities across this country
this evening well U.S defense officials
say the Russian invasion of Ukraine is
advancing along three lines of attack
established yesterday but the assault on
Kiev is taking longer than the Kremlin
anticipated Michael Clarke professor of
War studies at King's College London has
been looking at the Russian advance
we know that Russian troops have been
stretching the Ukrainian defenses with a
multi-pronged attack the British
Ministry of Defense defense information
in the mod have produced some estimates
of where they think the forces are and
they confirm more or less what we've
been saying that forces in Crimea have
moved North and and eastwards that
forces from Belarus have moved towards
Kiev and are in the north of Kiev but
forces up in the Northwest have not done
as well and seem to have been held
particularly at a place like chernov
that doesn't appear that they've got
through that very easily and so some of
these forces are more slow arriving in
Kiev than they expected to be let's just
have a look at what's happening in the
donbass the donbass region is where all
this started what in a sense this was
supposed to be all about and as expected
Russian forces have moved out of Crimea
and were expected to move from the
donbass region itself to actually link
up it doesn't look as if they've made it
because Ukrainian forces seem to be
holding them even though they're caught
in some something of a pincer in the
donbass region but it looks as if some
of the fighting there has been fairly
Fierce and at least from an immediate
perspective has actually helped the
ukrainians but of course the big issue
is Kiev what is happening in Kiev let's
just have a look at the satellite
photograph
um in Kiev we know that Russian forces
have effectively arrived in the northern
part of the city they are in The Oblong
District of the on the edge of it and
one would expect them to be able to move
in if they wanted to we also know that
Russian forces have arrived in the west
of the city there is no sign yet that
Russian forces have made it in similar
situations in the East or the south of
the city maybe because they haven't been
able to get there as quickly as was
expected we also know that there have
been fights at the hospital Airfield and
some uh Conflict at the borisville
airport
the fact is that Kiev in a sense is is
like a clock at 10 o'clock uh at 12
o'clock 10 o'clock and nine o'clock the
Russians know that their forces are
there they're waiting to complete the
circle and when Kiev is encircled then
they have the choice as to what to do
next and whether to actually tell the
Ukrainian government just to go or to
move in and remove them
Michael Clark there will uh security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes is with me
now and Deborah from what we're hearing
this evening uh it sounds as if the
Russians may be getting closer to this
capital city yes well this evening the
um the UK's chief of Defense
intelligence very unusually issued
another statement we normally never hear
from him publicly and this is the second
time I think since this crisis started
that he's chosen to go on the record to
be quoted and he says about the attack
by the Russians on Kiev and that they
are coming on they're advancing towards
the capital on two axes he says that
their objective is to encircle the
capital secure control of the population
and change the regime and that does
really sort of fit in with what we're
hearing that the ultimate goal here is
not to occupy the country but to change
the top of the government and impose a a
puppet regime effectively that would
have greater leading a greater leaning
towards Moscow and reject NATO EU
membership but the idea of that having
long-term success in a population that
clearly is opposed the majority seems to
be opposed to that idea it does seem to
indicate that this could turn really
ugly and then we're also seeing these
incredible images today aren't we of the
civilians being told to come forward and
take up weapons learn how to make
molotov cocktails the idea that yes the
Ukrainian military is clearly putting up
a defense but it is against a far
superior military force in the Russians
but the idea now that civilians are
being encouraged as well to defend
themselves does really underline the
stage that we're at right now the
president did this sort of selfie video
this evening where he's with some of his
key ministers really giving that message
that he is here not going anywhere and
clearly wanting people to know that he
hasn't left Kiev
so help me out here if President Putin
says he doesn't want to occupy this
country how does he succeed in what he's
in what he's trying to do it would seem
to be very very difficult for him as you
say it doesn't it does seem a confused
strategy and I mean that's why you hear
from British ministers and American
ministers saying this is this is this is
going to end badly this is a disaster
he's not going to achieve what he wants
to achieve it will be a disaster for
this country and for European security
but the fact is that he has attacked
across the entire breadth of this
country this country from the north east
and the South it seems he he wants to to
prevent that very skilled highly
equipped uh Ukrainian force in the East
that has been battling for eight years
against separatists russia-backed
separatists there from being able to
mount a defense of the capital and then
that frees him up in theory to be able
to make this move but I guess from what
we're hearing tonight you know we've
heard quite a successive number of of
explosions the idea perhaps that tonight
there will be more airstrikes against
various targets the idea that they have
was to take out Ukraine's air defense
system but it does seem that they the
ukrainians are still able to Target
Russian aircraft there was a Russian jet
that seemed to have been shot out the
sky today well overnight
um so yeah not over yet by any stretch
in fact just beginning and for the
capital tonight again very tense yeah
very tense and it's difficult to see how
this works out as you say for Vladimir
Putin or anyone yeah absolutely Deborah
thanks very much indeed and uh well
Vladimir Putin has called on Ukraine's
military to seize power in the country
to make negotiations with Russia easier
President Putin claimed he was ready for
talks but would prefer not to negotiate
with what he called the Nazis currently
in charge Diana magnet has this report
outside Ukraine's shattered Embassy in
Moscow police and a few mournful flowers
in solidarity
this woman though with placard saying
one people one Fatherland is all for the
war do you think it is okay for Russia
to bomb Kiev and kharkiv
news
that news is not shown on the state
channels but these two saw it on
Instagram and they hate it a lot of
people think that it's really terrible
all of us
aren't agree with this situation
Russia's foreign minister met today with
representatives of the separatist
republics repeating Vladimir Putin's
extraordinary logic that by invading
Ukraine he means to set its people free
he confirmed it again that we want
Ukrainian people to be independent and
have a government representing their
diversity have a freedom to not be under
full external control of those who
encourage neo-nazism the genocide of
Russians and using Ukraine as an
instrument to suppress Russia
Sky News asked the foreign Ministry if
President Putin was in his right mind
Sky News
Russian's defense secretary has said
that Vladimir Putin has gone full Tonto
and his English slang for completely mad
it's surprising that such evaluations
given by I mean defense minister of the
UK regarding
authorities of a different state I think
he could have thought up of a similar
adjectives
thinking of British prime minister if we
talk about personal uh judgment
as evening Falls Police prepare for
another possible night of protests
because not everyone by a long way
supports what their government is doing
I feel myself shared being ashamed for
being Russian we're all going to burn in
hell for that what we're doing I hope
Ukraine's will be
they will forgive us someday because now
I know first time I feel the shame that
I'm a citizen of Russian Federation
Facebook now is being restricted and
we'll see which social media platforms
are squeezed next
feels a little like a rerun of the
protests against Alexei navalny's
imprisonment all of which ended up with
thousands of people across the country
detained put in the back of police vans
as happened yesterday in more than 50
cities across Russia people coming out
against the war and promptly being
arrested
but it's not stopping them in Moscow the
crowds grew
and in St Petersburg too this anti-war
movement has some life in it yet
Sky News Moscow
so there we are protesting Moscow
protests also taking place in London
tonight with hundreds of Ukraine
supporters Gathering outside Downing
Street Skies Nick Martin is there Nick
what's going on
yeah good evening Mark quite a sizable
demonstration developing here in
Whitehall just to our left here is
Downing Street and this is where a lot
of these people are projecting their
voices saying arm Ukraine protect the
skies lots of people here tonight with
their banners Ukraine Will Never
Surrender please support Ukraine and
just take a look at this because
westminster's behind us Downing Street
is to our left and there is a long line
of people here protesting and
demonstrating here tonight trying to get
their voice heard what they want is the
UK government to support Ukraine more
than they already are many people here
are trying to encourage the British to
introduce a no-fly zone over Ukraine and
that's something that NATO has been very
reluctant to do they fear that that
could cause a conflict which could be
catastrophic but try telling that to
some of the people here and as I say the
line just continues to go on and on with
people holding their banners stop
putting now I'm Russian I'm against this
war Europe stand with Ukraine band Swift
the reference to the Banning of that
international finance system that many
people could believe could could rush
her off even more financially NATO stand
with Ukraine I mean the line goes on and
on and on up Whitehall here tonight
there was a protest here yesterday but
it was nowhere near this size Putin
stopped the war stop the war let's just
chat to this to this lady can I ask you
why you've come here tonight
you guys okay
to ask for my family
because I know in Ukraine and in danger
ous tonight as you can see a very big
demonstration here stretching all the
way from Downing Street all the way up
nearly to Trafalgar Square
okay Nick thanks very much indeed
sizable protests there in London well
every day next week we'll have a special
program twice a day on the Russian
invasion of Ukraine we'll bring you the
latest news from across the country as
well as uh correspondence in Washington
in Westminster and of course across
Europe that's Ukraine Invasion at 1pm
and 7 P.M every day from Monday
this is Sky News Tonight coming up calls
for the West to step up sanctions I'll
be speaking to the chess Grand Master
Gary Kasparov
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back NATO has announced plans to
bolster its eastern flank in response to
Russia's aggression here and the U.N
security Council will vote tonight on a
resolution condemning Russia's actions
Russia the current president of the
security Council will veto that
resolution our U.S correspondent Mark
stone is in Washington Laura bundock is
in Brussels let's go to Mark Stone first
so mark one wonders
um you know what is the point of a
security Council a resolution if we know
Russia is quite clearly going to veto it
a very good question that many people
will ask and the answer is isolation at
the top body the top diplomatic body of
the world the desire from Western
diplomats is to do all they can to try
and uh send a very clear message of
isolation to Russia the ones that the
the country to watch will be China if
China abstains rather than votes against
to in other words if China doesn't vote
with Russia but abstains instead from a
western diplomatic point of view that
will be very significant because it will
show that China is not happy with the
way Russia is uh conducting itself in
Ukraine that's important we'll see about
that later I think Ned price the state
department spokesman is currently giving
an update uh down the road from here at
the state department let's dip into that
Crimea is Ukraine
Ukrainian people have known 30 years of
Independence and while building their
democracy they have shown Relentless and
inspiring pursuit of Liberty of Peace of
security of human dignity and they
continue to show that they will not go
back in time
as we approach the seventh anniversary
of the brutal murder of Boris nemsoff we
are reminded that many Russians disagree
with Putin's brutal and imperialist
tactics and policies the citizens of
Russia who are peacefully protesting
including in Putin's own Hometown and in
dozens of other cities across the
Russian Federation are rejecting his
violence against the people of Ukraine
we deeply respect them we respect their
bravery we respect their heroism they
are out in the streets demanding that
Russia's government their government
stop this unprovoked and unjustified War
we've seen leading Russian journalists
denouncing Putin's war of choice we have
heard of Russia's mothers concerned
about the Reckless deployment of their
sons to a needless War
these courageous people of conscious
conscience in Russia persist they
persist despite the kremlin's
reinvigorated Crackdown this too is
classic from Putin's Playbook
whenever challenged by people his own
people speaking truth and opposing views
his tactic is to silence them
the people of Russia as we have said
time and again are not our enemy we hold
President Putin and his cronies
responsible for this war not them we
join you in saying no to war nit VI Mia
President Biden has said from the start
of this crisis if President Putin
chooses to invade the cost to Russia
will be immediate and profound
to its Financial system to its economy
to its technological base and to its
strategic position and Ambitions as well
as its reputation in the world
and the world has now witnessed that
Putin has made a choice he rejected
diplomacy he has chosen war and
President Biden has announced our
response
to be clear this is not the outcome we
want it this is not the outcome
we sought to prevent it's both a tragedy
for the people of Ukraine and a choice
Putin made that he that he has decided
for the people of Russia this is a
choice that has been decided for them
not by them Putin's war of choice has
required that we follow through on
imposing the massive consequences and
severe costs and that we ensure his
flagrant violation of international law
will be a strategic failure We Stand
United with our NATO allies and partners
in Europe and around the world and
confronting the Russian government and
holding President Putin and those around
him to account
right I just want to you
so that's Ned price the spokesperson for
the state department I think what what
would it be interesting and what would
be worth watching for the rest of the
afternoon Washington time is whether or
not any announcement comes from the
United States about sanctions directly
on President Putin and perhaps on
foreign minister Sergey lavrov for
reasons that are simply not entirely
clear the re Americans have been pretty
reluctant uh so far to impose direct
sanctions on these two people at the top
of the Russian regime
um yesterday in the briefing here at the
White House the spokesperson here was
asked repeatedly why not just that what
will it take to sanction President Putin
himself and the the spokesperson for
President Biden simply dodged the
question
um so look out for that today I've also
just heard that that security council
meeting has now been delayed until at
least 4 pm it was due to be at 3 P.M I
think that is probably because they're
watering down the language in the
resolution in order to try and get more
more people China India as well is
potentially wobbling on on uh certainly
is is equivocal in its um condemnation
of of Russia trying to water down the
language to get more countries uh on
board a talking shop yes but uh very
much as far as diplomats are concerned a
a way of sending the strongest possible
message to to isolate Russia and to
cement that isolation
okay mark thank you very much let's go
to Laura bundock in Brussels now and uh
Laura
um the EUR
certainly thinking about
um sanctioning a Putin and lavrov his
foreign minister directly
not even thinking about it but actually
doing it now you've finally agreed that
um that they will be adding Putin adding
lavrov to the list of sanctioned people
uh which means their assets within the
EU will now be frozen President Putin
joining the lights of Assad and Syria
lukashenko and Belarus as world leaders
sanctioned by the EU what does that mean
well it's very much a symbolic gesture
and another one to show and highlight
the isolation of Russia from the rest of
the world in terms of what assets the
pair have within the EU well the head of
EU foreign policy Joseph Burrell said
I'm not in the secrets of the well for
Putin and lavrov but he added there are
people who will take care of that now in
terms of the rest of the sanctions
package this second tranche of sanctions
we've been hearing about it sanctions on
the financial system targeting 70
percent of Russian banking services also
sanctions on energy on visas on
transport and on exports and on also
regimes and individuals who are
financially supporting and funding the
Russian regime big questions though
about the Swift International banking
system could that come in a third wave
of sanctions well certainly not yet uh
but Joseph Burrell said today nothing is
off the table he said maybe it could be
adopted in the coming days that he said
would depend on Putin's behavior and
let's not forget it would also depend on
getting agreement of all the EU 27
countries and I think getting them all
to agree on that would be a trickier job
with some countries than with other
countries when it comes to cutting
Russia out of Swift
okay Laura thank you very much so
European countries uh discussing further
sanctions or deciding on further
sanctions on Russia among the measures
they're considering as Laura bundock was
just saying there is a ban on the use of
the Swift uh payment uh Network so a
number of sanctions being introduced by
Europe and uh the Western allies that
could have a real impact on Vladimir
Putin and his cronies well I can speak
now to the chess Grand Master uh human
rights campaigner Gary Kasparov thank
you very much indeed for being with us
we are seeing and seeing on this program
protests across Russia will this bother
Vladimir Putin at all
no
Hilton has enough resources to put down
any products in Russia he has a war
chest with hundreds of billions of
dollars enough to pay for propaganda for
military and also for police
a I upload the heroism of tens of
thousands of people who made it to the
streets of Russian cities yesterday and
still doing it today but they they
cannot change uh Putin's mind he has
enough police uh security apparatus to
um arrest arrest thousands of people as
he did yesterday many of them by the way
will probably spend years in jail and as
long as he keeps this war chest and as
long as he controls hundreds of billions
of dollars and looks Invincible for his
Cronus in Russia I don't think that any
protests on Russian streets will change
anything
the fact he's doing it though what does
it say about his mindset and his well
his goals
uh well uh he's in power for more than
20 years so that's why I suggest
strongly suggest that you stop using
word president he's a dictator it is
illegal and he doesn't care about
elections it's just a window for the
rest of the world to show that uh there
are still some remnants of democracy in
Russia
uh he's at war with the uh with the Free
World so he believes that we have to go
back uh on time as he said 15 years ago
in Munich at security conference on
February 2007 when he declared his
intention to return to the what he
called spheres of influence and he was
very consistent by developing this
strategy so 50 years later you can look
at the results of of Putin's strategy of
um
subduing uh Russian neighbors that were
not ready to leave on the Russian
influence and even spreading his
influence across the world look at Syria
many African countries Venezuela and now
in Ukraine he's not simply fighting to
destroy Ukraine which by the way he
never never recognized Ukraine as an
independent Sovereign Nation he's
destroying and I have to say he's
probably already succeeded the uh Global
Security infrastructure that has been
built uh since the World War II because
if a stronger country with with
um strong military uh can attack the
neighborhood neighboring country with
the world uh yeah it's uh waffling and
mumbling so that's a signal to everybody
and of course China is watching very
closely I I'm I'm shocked to hear that
all these talks about watering down the
resolution to make sure China withdraws
who cares people's lives are at stake
and eventually Putin succeeds in Ukraine
China will use this formula for Taiwan
but if you know the sanctions hit the
economy
um collapses uh the protests continue
can you see any chance at all of this
being the beginning of the end of Putin
oh you you made you made a very
important point if sanctions hate the
economy and then look closely at what
Americans did or Europeans did they left
Russian Central Bank and the bear Bank
out out of the of the war sanctions
there's Burbank Assets in America not
being ceased uh or frozen so yes the the
sanctions uh would cause uh certain
problems for Russian economy but those
are the sanctions if you look at least
had to be imposed eight years ago after
annexation of Crimea now it's too little
and too late to stop Putin and also all
this talks about sanctioning Putin who
cares Putin doesn't doesn't assets in
Europe or lavrov you have to go off the
oligarchs you know the addresses you
know just look around in London uh in
many European countries so if you want
to hit Putin follow the money and you
have to hit his wallets and symbolic
sanctions against Putin or lavrov or
other top officials that are not
affecting Putin directly it's just it's
again it's symbolic it's more like
paying paying lip service and of course
uh supplying Ukraine with weapons it was
long overdue and only now we hear a very
slow uh uh move in this direction but
I'm afraid it might be again too little
too late
all right Gary Kasparov I appreciate
your time thank you very much indeed
thank you
well residents of this city have been
asked to make fire bombs to help
neutralize Russian forces pictures of
emerged of people queuing for guns with
the government saying thousands of
weapons uh have been handed out members
of parliament have also armed themselves
uh among them theater slav urash
Ukraine's youngest MP last night he
shared this image of him carrying an
AK-47 on the streets of Kiev and he
joins me now
um well thank you very much for being
with us first of all can you believe
while you're walking around the streets
there can you believe what is happening
to your city and your country
if I'm talking with you there's there
are explosions in distance basically
happening I'm trying to overall nicotine
I need to sorry and say help the
soldiers
and do you do you
do I don't think you can hear me we
can't hear you now
checking my documentation basically I'll
I'll be with you in a second one moment
so
you're back with us okay I just wondered
are you do you feel safe yourself do you
feel that you and your family are safe
I will be joining
with the fighting for Kiev because
there's no other choice now we have 14
key of today we have had Russian cursing
the north of the city we have Russian
Collins heading for the north for the
eastern part of town and we have to
stand that ground this is our Capital
which we cannot give up my family I am
from the Western Ukraine so my family is
there and even though every city in
Ukraine and my hometown as well were hit
by uh by missiles from Russia and
different kinds of attacks still they're
safe for them here but I'm staying in
the capital because that's the only
honorable thing to do for a person who
wants to his country to survive this
onslaught
and if the Russians come into the
capital would you stay in the capital or
would you then leave
they are in the capital today they'll be
fighting in Norfolk City and they are
dropping Rockets yes here the explosions
as I'm walking
to the center of town to the area where
the presidential Administration made an
appeal today to the citizen Ukraine
showing the presidency here prime
minister is here leadership is here to
defend our capital
not to allow Russians to win
no matter what
and if the Russians do come in and put
in another government and remove
president zielinski how would the people
of Kiev and the people of Ukraine react
to that
it's not about the government it's not
about zelenski uh Russians Mr Putin made
a long hour-long speech that the whole
world can see available to you ever on
every social media that features about
his
firm belief that Ukraine is one nation
Ukraine is another state and that he
wants to take over Ukraine he wants
Ukraine to be a part of Russia
ukrainians by every measure every poll
don't agree with that statement so we
were going to fight
with everything we got to the very end
to keep our nation away from him
and do you see a long war of resistance
if they come in and they topple the
government do you see a war of
resistance happening
I was born
the Soviet Union I only know Ukraine and
there are millions like me would not
even dare to presume anything else but
independent Ukraine and we will fight to
keep that independent Ukraine a reality
no matter
the putting what putting puts on the
table no matter what he puts against us
again we did for the last two days
Ukraine's been fighting a war on every
border with Russia
from the south the north the East and
we've seen plenty of that instruments
plenty of their Weaponry we captured
many of their prisoners
we destroyed very many as well and we
shown okay um is that your weapon you
have with you now serious love yes
yes
it's the AK
basically I'm you know why I'm talking
working with because I have to get home
before curfew to then in the morning go
north of here to the area where some
Russian columns are and one of my
teammates sitting in the fence trying to
put one with the other yes we've got to
leave it there uh try and stay safe and
thank you for being with us we've got uh
thank you very much on the program uh
and all I can say is thank you very much
indeed around us several explosions uh
the fighting continues here with a
vengeance
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]